This is a download from BBC Learning English. To find out more, visit our website.
Hello, this is 6 Minute English from BBC Learning English. I'm Neil.
And I'm Georgina.
Last November, NASA launched a very unusual home delivery service,
a rocket carrying four tons of supplies to the ISS, the International Space Station.
Among the scientific equipment were 12 bottles of red wine from the famous Bordeaux region of France.
The astronauts might have wanted a glass of wine with dinner,
but the real purpose of the bottles was to explore the possibility of producing food and drink in space,
not for astronauts, but for people back on Earth.
In today's programme, we'll be finding out how growing plants in space can develop crops,
which are more productive and more resistant to climate change here on Earth.
And we'll hear how plants can grow in environments with little or no natural light.
But first today's quiz question, what was the first food grown in space?
Was it A, potatoes, B, lettuce or sea tomatoes?
Mmm, well, in the film The Martian, a stranded astronaut grows potatoes on Mars.
I know it's only a film, but I'll say A, potatoes.
Okay, we'll find out the answer later.
Now, you might be wondering how it's possible to grow plants without natural light.
British company Vertical Future has been working on this problem
by developing indoor farming methods in partnership with NASA.
Here's their head of research, Jen Bromley, explaining the process to BBC World Service programme, The Food Chain.
Basically, we use LED lighting, and we use LED lights that are tuned to specific wavelengths.
So if you imagine what the rainbow looks like, the reason a plant looks green
is because it's not using all the green light, it actually reflects a lot of that back.
So the reason why it looks pink in here is because we're actually only using red light and blue light
to grade the plants. And that essentially tailors the light diet,
so that the plants look kind of black when you look at them, because they're not reflecting any light,
they're being super efficient. They're using up every photon that hits them.
The lack of natural light in space means that plants are grown using LED lights.
LED is an abbreviation of light emitting diode, an electronic device that lights up when electricity is passed through it.
On Earth, plants look green because they reflect back any light traveling at a certain wavelength.
The distance between two waves of light, which makes things appear to us in the various colours of the rainbow.
But when scientists control the wavelengths being fed, plants are able to absorb every photon,
particle of light energy, making them appear black.
Each particle of light that hits the leaves is absorbed and through photosynthesis
is converted into plant food. NASA found that different colour combinations or light
recipes can change a plant's shape, size and even flavour.
But the lack of natural light isn't the biggest obstacle to growing food in space.
Here's Joy Amassa, Chief Plant Scientist at the Kennedy Space Centre in Florida to explain.
Microgravity is really challenging, but plants are amazing. They can adapt to so many different
environments, and we call this plasticity, because they can turn on or off their genes to really
adapt to all sorts of conditions, and that's why you see plants growing in different areas on
Earth, the same type of plant may look very different because it's adapting to the environment in
that specific location. On Earth, plants use gravity to position themselves, shoots grow up,
roots grow down, but this doesn't apply in space because of microgravity. The weaker pull of
gravity, making things float and seem weightless. Plants can only survive in these conditions,
due to their plasticity, the ability of living organisms to adapt and cope with changes in
the environment by changing their biological structure. Plants adapt themselves to being in space
by manipulating their genes. Chemicals and DNA in the cells of plants and animals which control
their development and behaviour. In the low-gravity atmosphere of space, plants become stressed,
but they adapt genetically. And as a result, they're stronger and more resilient to other
less-dressful events when they return home to Earth. Like those bottles of red wine orbiting
Earth as we speak, the effects of microgravity on the wine's organic composition will be studied
and could hopefully offer solutions for growing food in Earth's changing climate.
So Neil, if it wasn't red grapes, what was the first food grown in space?
Ah yes, in today's quiz question, I asked what the first plant grown in space was.
I said A potatoes. But in fact it was. B, lettuce grown over 15 months on the ISS,
and eaten in 15 minutes in the first ever space salad.
Today we've been discussing the possibilities of growing plants in space using LED lights,
devices that use electricity to produce light.
The energy needed for plants to grow is contained in photons or light particles traveling at
different wavelengths. Distances between light waves which make things look different colors.
Plants have evolved over millennia using the strong gravity on Earth, but this changes in space
because of microgravity. The weaker gravitational pull, making things in space float and seem
to be a bit more weightless. Luckily plants use their genes, the chemicals in DNA responsible for
growth, to adapt to new environments by changing their biological structure, a process known as
plasticity. All of which makes it possible for astronauts to enjoy a glass of wine and green
salad in space. And genetically stronger plant specimens to study back on Earth.
That's all for today, but join us again soon at 6 Minute English. Bye for now. Bye.
From the BBC.